Hi, everyone.
My name is Liz
Roten and today I'm
going to talk to
you about how you
can take the project
that you really hate
and turn it into something
oddly satisfying.
So this adventure starts
with a truck, or rather
a truck corridor study.
Hey, there we go.
My manager pitched
this project to me
as a straightforward,
quick data science win.
The only thing we needed
to do was update the data.
All of the methods and
extra analysis were settled.
It was going to be very easy.
And it wasn't.
And my first inkling
of this was when
I started to look into
the project materials.
They were bad.
They were pretty bad.
And how bad are we talking here?
So on the left, you can
see a bunch of files
and the font is way too small
because there are simply
too many.
And there are a couple of
things I want to point out.
So there are multiple
final reports.
And the problem, when
you have something
and you name it and you
have multiple things
and you name all of them final.
The word final stops
meaning anything.
There's no telling what actually
truly is the final document.
There are also
multiple documents
that were marked as revised.
Great, marked as
revised! And marked
revised maybe August
11th or August 14th.
However, when this
project first took place,
it took place over
more than one year.
So was it August 2017 or 2018?
I don't have any
information from that,
and I don't know who modified it
or revised it, when they revised
it, or why it was revised.
And there is a single Excel
workbook with all the analysis,
including a worksheet with over
15,000 rows and a whole bunch
of nasty formulas that
will make your skin crawl.
And so now that I've
introduced you to this mess,
I'd like to pivot to
something a little better.
And it's this
internet phenomenon
of things that are
oddly satisfying.
So oddly satisfying things is a
content of--a genre of content,
and it's generally
something like someone
taking something super dirty
and making it pristinely clean
or painting something
very precisely.
I, in my opinion,
find this tiny crab
holding up a tiny
fish very satisfying
with the composition.
You have the yellow and
the blue and the foreground
and the background.
I think it's satisfying, but in
case that doesn't really do it
for you, I have a couple more.
So this first video is of
a person with a smoothie.
They add this purple
powder into the smoothie
and you see the color
come in to the smoothie
as it's like smoothing around.
And it's very
mesmerizing and lovely.
And I have one more.
And that's of a person using.
A turntable to ice a tart.
So you see the
little tart, you see
the turntable
turning and a person
using a piping bag to
pipe this perfect spiral.
And then once the
spiral is complete,
they grab a blowtorch, get
a little color on there,
and finally they pan over to
all of the other absolutely
beautiful identical tarts.
And there's something
about these videos
that just soothes my soul.
And so I had this moment of
"What if I take the truck study
and make it this satisfying?"
I essentially decided
to take my truck
that made me very
sad and turn it
into the best truck
that has ever existed.
And I learned a few
things along the way
that I'd like to share with you.
And they come in 3.
First, assess the damage.
Second, do and document.
And finally, leave a gift.
So, let's assess the damage.
You're essentially going to
complete a project intake.
Start by reading
through everything
and I mean actually everything.
The more you read through
now, the fewer surprises
you're going to have later
on and the better feel
you're going to have
for the project itself.
As you're doing
this, you're going
to make a hate list,
which is a list of all
of the things about this
project that you hate.
Maybe the
documentation is vague,
maybe the documentation
and the calculation
aren't doing the same thing
that they should be doing.
Whatever it is, write it down
and put it aside for later.
You're also going to
replicate your findings
or the results from the
previous study, if applicable.
And this is going to test
your knowledge of this project,
and it's going to give
you an opportunity
to work through it hands-on.
And even if the
numbers don't align
exactly, you need to be able to
explain why they don't align
exactly. Was it a rounding
issue, or a data source issue?
Whatever it is, you
just need to explain it.
And the most important
part of your intake
is finding your thing.
And your thing is this
one aspect, or multiple,
of your professional life
that makes you excited.
Something that you know you can
work on and you can be proud of,
and you're going to
find a way to apply
your thing to this project.
Maybe you're really into plot.
You're going to go out and find
all of the ggplot2 extensions
and make beautiful plots.
Or perhaps you're into maps.
You're going to make some maps
with some excellent legend
legend work, and it'll
all look wonderful.
Or maybe you're into
speed and efficiency.
Break out all of your vector-
based programming skills
and make this thing
lightning fast.
Whatever it is, it's
important that it's yours.
And it's important
it's important that you
get excited about doing it.
Your thing is what's going
to power this project,
and it will also keep you sane.
And my thing is documentation.
If you're ever unsure
of what your thing could
be with a project,
try documentation.
And that leads us to the
second part to do and document.
So you're going to do the
thing, complete the work,
and you're going to
document along the way.
There is one sentence
that I think encapsulates
why documentation is
so important, better
than anything else, and that is
this quote that "Documentation
is a love letter to
your future self."
And this is the
attitude you want
to go into documentation with.
And there are folks
across this conference
that will preach to you the
gospel of documentation.
But there are a couple of
things I would like to add in.
One of them is to modularize,
which we did hear about a bit
this morning in the keynote.
So, like this
beautiful tart,
every slice can be
divided up equally
and stand on its own.
And you want to treat
your code like this.
Generally, how do you
know if you need to
modularize your code.
If you have a single script with
more than 500 lines, too long,
you should consider modularization.
If you're doing more
than two scrolls,
it's not going to
be sustainable.
So on the left
there is some code
that does some
spatial processing
and will take a while to run.
It also depends on loading
in a bunch of data sets
and having libraries
in your environment.
And that's fine.
It'll run.
And the script is going
to take a long time.
But if you
modularized, you can go
into a few different, you can
create scripts that are named
according to what they do.
So load packages does
nothing but load packages
for a solid 15 lines.
Load data only loads the data.
It doesn't do any extra
modeling or spatial processing.
It just loads the data.
And they don't have
to be completely independent.
If they need to
run sequentially,
you can name them
1, 2, 3 and that
gives you a signal that they
need to be run sequentially.
I'd also like to advocate for a
bespoke README or a very fancy
README. A README is an
explanatory document that
accompanies computer files
or software, according
to Wikipedia, and
I think it gets
overlooked in data science,
from my observation.
There are three parts
of a README that
make it truly bespoke
and fancy: context, structure,
and key information.
So your context should
answer the questions:
What even is this thing?
Why does this thing exist
and what is its history?
Answer these questions
in the beginning of your
README and it will ground
this project in what
the truth and the
true meaning of why
you're even working on this.
The second is structure.
How is everything organized?
Where does the data live?
Where do you actually do the
thing to run the analysis
and get the output?
And this will also force you to
take a step back from your code
and think about it in a
more structural manner.
And finally, key information.
This is where you
break out the hate list
and you're going to do the
exact opposite of the hate list.
You're going to turn
it into a love list.
And your key information
should answer
the question of at the
most fundamental level,
what is the operative
component and how is it done?
So with the truck
corridor study, it
it was a weighted
mean, which wasn't
apparent from the beginning.
And so instead of
leaving it a mystery,
I added it in a snippet of code
that doesn't by itself run,
but it gives what is the
most important information.
And that's my next
and final part,
is to leave a gift,
not a mystery.
I have one more video for you.
This is of a person--loading--
a person using a,
gift-wrapping a gift with very
precise, clean lines,
and they add a little
bit of nature at the end,
and it is presented
on a linen tablecloth
with candles and pine cones.
And I would be utterly delighted
to find a gift like that.
And this is the
energy you want to bring
in to your project debrief.
The first thing to do
is to take a break.
Once the project is done,
really, truly, actually done,
shut it,
put it away, and don't look at it
for at least two, three weeks,
and then you're
going to come back
in and condense and clarify.
So as I was working
through the truck corridor study,
I made something like nine
R Markdowns and most of them
did not go anywhere.
Either they were a dead end,
or some exploratory analysis,
or they were worked into some
other part of the analysis.
But you wouldn't know that just
from looking at these files.
And if you were going
to work on this project,
you would have to read
through all of these.
So instead I broke it down
into three R Markdowns.
A README--a bespoke README,--
a summary, and methods,
and it's much more
clear and concise.
And we have a
couple aspects that
are inside those markdowns.
In the markdowns,
I've documented not
only what, but why.
So, what?
We used 2019 traffic data.
That could be a full sentence.
If I'm looking at
this in the future.
And I see that this project
was taking place in 2021,
and they'd already released
the 2020 data, why in the world
would they use 2019?
And it's likely obvious
to most of us that
2020 was quite anomalous, which
is why we use the 2020 data.
It was quite anomalous, also
known as a garbage fire.
Additionally, we set--all of
the corridors were given scores
and those scores were
broken into tiers,
and we set the tier breaks
at 15.4 and 26.2 points.
It was a very specific,
and it was important.
It's not 15.5, it's
15.4 and not 26.2 or 30,
it's exactly 26.2.
So why would we do that?
Because our
transportation planners
used their best judgment,
given a wide array of factors
outside of just these numbers.
I also really advocate
for reproducibility.
You want to record
package versions,
and there are lots
of ways that you
can do this, including tools
like groundhog, pak, or renv,
take your pick.
Just be consistent.
I'm also a big fan of a
good timestamped output.
You can integrate a time stamp
into the name of the file
that you're outputting,
or you can implement it
in a column in a dataframe.
Whatever you do, you need to
have a year, month, and day.
All three.
So this project is
done for me for now.
And I would love to
tell you about how
I came to love trucks and see
their importance in the Twin
Cities region and how they are
perfect for our future economic
opportunities.
But I still don't
care about trucks.
They're
just not my thing.
But every single
person in my office
knows about the documentation
I made for this project.
And I am so proud of the
work I did about something
I don't care about.
And so at the end of it,
I'm feeling less like,
Oh, I don't care about this.
I feel a lot like
this little crab.
But instead of a fish,
I'm holding up a truck.
Thank you.